[موسيقى]
منتنون للغايه لدول الخليج لدعمها
اوكرانيا على دعمها السياسي في الواقع دول
الخليج تدعم جميع القرارات في الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده فهي تدعم جميع
القرارات السياسيه دعنا نقل قرارات
اوكرانيا والشركاء نحن نقدر ذلك ونحن
ممتنون لها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تنفذها بشكل منفصل وهي رائده في تنفيذ
الدعم الانساني لاوكرانيا
تم تخصيص اكثر من 410 ملايين دولار خصيصا
للدعم الاجتماعي الانساني للاوكرانيين هذه
هي الاكبر في الاستثمار بين دول الخليج في
دعم المشروعات الانسانيه والاجتماعيه في
اوكرانيا اضافه الى ذلك دعم الامارات
العربيه المتحده ايضا كما تقدم دول الخليج
الاخرى الدعم المناسب لاوكرانيا ونحن نقدر
ذلك بعمق ونشعر بالامتناء
[موسيقى]
لدينا افاق جيده من حيث تطوير التعاون
التجاري والاقتصادي ونحن بالفعل ذو
الاهتماما لذلك بدءا من ديسمبر 2022 عندما
بدانا مفاوضات التعزيز التعاون الاقتصادي
ندع دول الخليج للمشاركه في مشروعات
المستقبل واعاده اعمار اوكرانيا بعد نهايه
هذه الحرب لدينا ايضا تعاون جيد جدا مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من حيث وضع
اتفاقيات تجاريه واقتصاديه جديده وكذلك
التعاون في الصناعه وفي جميع القطاعات من
الامن الغذائي الى التعاون التجاري في
مختلف قطاعات الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]